the indian city of jamnagar is a
money-making machine for asia's richest
man mukesh ambani
his company reliance has the world's
biggest oil refinery complex here in the
city producing 1.5 million barrels of
crude every day
john nagar is a district in gujarat it's
a coastal town if you
go to the place
it's mostly a vast arid stretch of land
and that is where ambani chose to build
a massive
complex and it kind of just stands out
in the landscape
jamnagar is also where ambani is making
his newest bet
a 10 billion dollar investment in green
energy
his ambition is closely aligned with the
indian government's plan to reach net
zero emissions by 2070 and expand its
renewable energy to record capacities
but ambani is not alone
india's second richest man gautama dhani
has committed 20 billion dollars of
investment over the next decade
the impact of two biggest business
tycoons entering into renewable will
create a lot of competition it will
bring in lots of investments it will
create plenty of jobs and it will push
prime minister's target of transiting
into a greener energy by 2030
but india's massive dependencies on
fossil fuels and plans to obtain more
coal from abroad have some environmental
advocates questioning the realism and
sincerity of those green ambitions and
those of its two biggest billionaires
with the power to drive india one of the
world's biggest greenhouse gas emitters
towards a green energy future are these
two billionaires ready to abandon their
fossil fuel fortunes
these two conglomerates the reliance
group and the adani group have set out
an extremely ambitious roadmap for
themselves ahead now the real test of
the pudding will be in the eating
[Applause]
[Music]
the people of the subcontinent of india
had been promised a certain degree of
self-rule by the british when india
gained independence in 1947 the next two
decades or so were marked by
soviet-style planning where there was a
government-led development plan
that began to change in 1970s when the
government slowly started stepping back
and that space was filled in by these
large business families who had
sprawling businesses across different
sectors that we now call conglomerates
the 1980s onwards is when reliance grew
under mukesh ambani's father the ruby
came into prominence that was an iconic
group much storied and made a lot of
wealth for its shareholders the adani
group in fact came a little bit later in
late 1980s but in prominence towards the
beginning of this century
okay somani is asia's religious person
among the religious in the world he
built his empire
on fossil fuels oil and petrochemicals
and lately he has started his telecom
venture which is doing pretty well and
is expected to grow even further
like mukesh ambani is another very smart
businessman he's a college dropout he
moved to diamond business and then later
on moved back to amdavad to join his
brother's plastic business before he
started his own
adani enterprises in the 80s
the conglomerate has businesses ranging
from ports to coal mining to running
airports
adani and ambani they're the two big
tycoons
people say that they're the modern day
rockefellers
today as india's rich entrepreneurs like
ambani and adani prosper the country's
inequality gap is widening
research shows that india's richest one
percent hold over four times the wealth
of the poorest 70 percent of the
country's population
so last couple of years of the pandemic
the stock market sprinted away and that
added a lot to the net worth of the
billionaires at the top end including
these two tycoons amani and adani there
were millions who couldn't find jobs who
saw their salaries being cut
some attribute the success of these
billionaires to their relationship with
the government
ambani and adani have aligned their
business strategies with prime minister
narendra modi's goals and made huge
fortunes
some critics have said that the
relationship between the adani group and
possibly the reliance group and the modi
administration is a bit too cozy
but that is something which
every stakeholder involved in this has
denied so adani ambani and modi all
three of them hail from the western
indian state of gujarat
ambani while he is now mumbai based has
a lot of assets like the world's biggest
refinery the twin complex of jamnagar in
gujarat and adani still has their base
in gujarat and they have power plants
and ports and a lot of infrastructure
so both these groups they have the roots
and a lot of source of their wealth tied
to that one state in which modi was the
chief minister for a decade before he
ascended and became the prime minister
of the country
last year the country's two richest men
came under attack over farming laws
protesters alleged that the laws were
designed to allow the billionaires to
enter the farming market the tycoons say
they have no such interest
now with the modi administration's
ambitions to move india the world's
third biggest emitter away from fossil
fuels ambani and adani are both making
big bets on green energy
since narendra modi took charge in 2014
his government has given tremendous
impetus on
clean energy
india's energy mix is extremely tilted
towards fossil fuels
around 45 percent comes from coal around
25 percent
comes from oil
gas again a fossil fuel slightly cleaner
fossil fuel has about six percent
biomass has a significant portion and
the balance that remains
is shared by
hydropower renewable energy and nuclear
power so these are still very very small
fractions in the overall energy mix
today
in total renewable energy we have just
about across 100 gigawatts and the
target now is to reach 175 gigawatt by
2022
and ultimately reach 450 gigawatts by
2030.
businesses that act on the urgent need
to limit
incremental global warming
will secure the largest opportunities
over the next several decades
in this race
to avoid ecological disaster
the world could use
indian leadership
adani green energy is one of the top
players in this field the company's main
business is solar energy generation and
it has a portfolio of about 15 gigawatts
of renewable energy 15 percent of the
country's total renewable capacity
although green energy has seen a lot of
investors interest in the last year
and the stock price has shot up 600
times that has added almost 20 billion
dollar to his net worth
but the billionaire wants more
adani green energy aims to become the
world's largest renewable energy company
and adani said he will invest 20 billion
dollars into the sector over the next
decade
but his journey to domination might not
be easy as mukesh ambani joins
the world is entering a new energy era
which is going to be highly destructive
ambani is known for a big disrupter
wherever he is entered he has actually
broken cost barriers telecom is the
latest example six seven years ago uh
people thought that
his his telecom venture jio was a small
company but today it's probably the
largest telecom uh service provider in
the country
good evening freelance jio they have
stormed the market all the existing
players they have been bleeding under
the stiff price competition that
reliance jio has brought in
reliance's main
business strategy has been the scale the
huge scale they bring in to every
business they get into there's a scale
that kind of bulldozes the competition
similarly he is going to replicate the
same skill in renewable space as well
ambani says he will invest 10 billion
dollars in solar green hydrogen
batteries and fuel cells in the next
three years overlapping with adani's
plan
both billionaires are also focusing on
manufacturing and making solar panels
could be one area in which they compete
fiercely
[Music]
there are two factors basically in
bringing down the cost of renewable
energy you need
cheaper solar modules and cheaper
capital cheaper capital is something
that both of these groups can leverage
the interesting thing about ambani's
plan is that in solar modules in india
ambani is the first one who is
attempting to make solar modules right
from the start of the value chain he's
planning to make polysilicon he's trying
to make wafers cells and modules
his idea is to bring down the cost even
further because right now india gets
about eighty percent of its module
supplies from china amani wants to
change that and he wants to show that
india can build
the
solar modules right from scratch
i am sure gauta madani will face a lot
of competition in the manufacturing side
from reliance in years to come
another battleground could be
manufacturing electrolyzers
electrolyzers are used to split water
into hydrogen and oxygen if the process
uses electricity generated by renewable
energy the hydrogen produced is called
green hydrogen
hydrogen is still a very nascent
renewable energy and everyone is talking
about
getting into green hydrogen no one in
india at least
have started producing green hydrogen so
far
but that's going to be the ultimate fuel
which everyone would love to have a
green hydrogen where cars the tailpipes
will only emit some little bit of
distilled water
mukesh ambani has gone on record saying
that he targets to produce green
hydrogen at one dollar per kg the
current rate is extremely costly all
over the world if reliance can
target one dollar per kg of hydrogen
that's going to be a
big game changer
adani has plans to produce cheap
hydrogen as well
we are strongly positioned
to produce
the world's
least expensive hydrogen
which is expected to be an energy source
plus
feedstock
for various industries
that we intend to play
the good thing of this is that it is
only
going
to help
indian renewable energy consumers
the government will be
really pleased with this competition
because when these two large businessmen
compete
the prospects are extremely bright for
costs to come down even further
but finding space to carry out all of
these ambitious projects is an imminent
challenge
land is a problem for everybody that
wants to set up an industrial base in
the country
many of the times you need to dislocate
people so there are issues about it
while adani hasn't secured lands to set
up manufacturing facilities ambani has
next door to his huge fossil fuels
complex in jamnagar reliance is building
solar and hydrogen plants with an aim to
help build 100 gigawatts of solar energy
by 2030
but reactions in the city have been
mixed
with
everybody wants green energy clean
energy i don't think that reliance will
be able to
diverse this
investment in a
refinery very soon
the age of fossil fuels which powered
economic growth globally for nearly
three centuries cannot continue much
longer
the huge quantities of carbon it has
emitted into the environment have
endangered life on earth
on the face of it this is a sharp pivot
for ambani's fossil fuel empire
but oil is still king contributing
nearly 60 percent of reliance's 73
billion dollars in annual revenue
that is a sore point the company despite
growing in the renewable energy sector
it will keep on making good money out of
fossil fuels i'm not sure when when they
want to actually
completely get away from fossil fuels
that that
is not
on the horizon
a report has shown that adani is also
boosting fossil fuel assets despite
vowing to be carbon neutral
so we found that adani is looking to
roughly double its coal-fired power
capacity from 12 to 24 gigawatts through
the construction of four new coal-fired
power stations and the expansion of at
least two
existing plants
one of them is the carmichael coal mine
in queensland australia
the company plans to transport the coal
from australia to countries in asia
including india
the project has been under fire from
environmental activists and been refused
funding from banks
from a climate perspective adani's
carmichael cole project is its most
dangerous of its new fossil fuel
projects it could become australia's
biggest coal mine and from the projects
that are currently proposed in the
galilee basin the coal burnt would use
up about six percent of humanity's
carbon budget for 1.5 degrees there is
no transportation infrastructure four
mines in that area they are getting the
approvals they are actually building
that first line in the galilee basin we
are very concerned that if that's
allowed to continue then more mines
could be built in the area and
that is just
billions of tons of gold that will make
it much much harder to hit the goals of
the paris agreement
but it also has green projects on the
anvil so the real question is that can
they ramp up their green projects to the
point where they can be carbon neutral
that's the objective and that's where
the real tightrope walk will come
moving away from fossil fuels is hard
not just for ambani and adani but for
india as a whole
modi has committed to reach net zero by
2070 but that's a big task
nearly 70 percent of the country's
electricity came from coal power plants
last year
for another few decades india is still
going to rely more on fossil fuels
although renewable share will move up
quite a bit going ahead
there is obviously a dilemma among the
energy policy makers that india has
abundant results of coal and how do you
kind of completely get away from it
emissions will keep coming from the
industries that use gold so how do
policy makers balance that out
in the very short term india's vast
population at the lower end may not
immediately benefit by the green
initiatives announced by the two tycoons
the only benefit that we can think of is
maybe more jobs coming through these
projects because it'll take time for
these projects to come online it depends
on how they're executed and how they
perform how they deliver those are the
variables that will determine the
roadmap for these conglomerates how
successful they are how they create
wealth or destroy it
[Music]
[Music]
you